harvey torno il tente maintenant en
ch'ti l'interprète immortel le laisse
béton a donné vendredi soir un concert
unique et gratuit en plein air à
wazemmes l'un des quartiers populaires
de l'île interprétant toutes ses
chansons en chimie le patois du nord
parmi les chansons les plus applaudis de
renault petit fils et arrière petit fils
de mineur et entre parenthèses héros du
prochain film germinal tout en haut de
ch'terril ou encore valence boire une
goutte juge
nos reporters nathalie dollé et j
-jacques qui ils sont levés de cayenne
tellement il est enthousiaste un vin
café avait été reportée en stimulant
leur ai pas parlé aux chignons plus et
je passe mes vacances
c'est donc enchanteur que renault est
revenu dans le nord un retour attendu
espéré depuis que l'acteur avait fini de
tourner germinal quand il avait
découvert les classiques populaires de
la région
j'ai su qu'il avait reçu très tard oui
je savais pas il le répéter le soir
non
et tant pis si n'attendez pas parfait
l'important c'est son renault vient
d'offrir 12 chansons en patois
assis devant sa famille tandis que samir
aux connaissances très simple tout c'est
tout rôle et ses fruits
c'est encore sensible donc pourquoi ça
vous touche t on pas je suis poète dans
l'âme
poetry
on six mois de tournage il s'est passé
quelque chose entre le temps d'un
chanteur révolter et les dizaines de
figurants du film quelque chose de très
fort
quelque chose au moins une fois par an
soit soir pendant 100 ans et le brevet
c'est que tout le monde y croit
une idée fort belle baie trajet par un
conflit dans leur ventre gens qui posent
soutien au caron
amaya cilic au comité